of course it is clear that the World As
We Knew It had changed and the
weaponization of the energy by Russia
has had enormous consequences in the
world in general in European Union in
particular so we experienced challenges
to the security of Supply Rising Energy
prices of course it happened it started
before the war but this exacerbated the
situation infrastructure bottleneck and
of course we have to keep in mind the
fact that the crisis is not over yet you
know that we are already working on the
fit 455 package and beside this normal
work and finishing the legislative
initiatives we uh also discussed debated
and took action on the short-term
emergency actions what was proposed by
European commissioned excellent measures
and once again I would like to thank
commissioner Kathy Simpson for the very
good operation and congratulate her and
her team for the good measures that
helped us to avoid major crisis
we I just give you an example and I'm
going versus the end of my my
intervention that together with the
council we defined obligations at EU
level of mandatory guest storage it had
proved to be a successful tool to
stabilize the volatility generated in
the markets by Russia's work of
aggression and also make us to be
prepared in case a sudden and total
Interruption took place this happened
very quick in two months after the
commission proposal was sent to the
college legislators and the cooperation
with the council was very good very good
and the team negotiating team leaded by
president buzek was very efficient also
we played a key role in defining how
member states could spend a
and support it to make some area funds
available to alleviate the effects on
citizens and companies of high energy
prices of course we supported the
commissions and member states efforts to
introduce joint purchases of guests to
pull demand and give you companies a
better negotiating positions we also
proposed and supported the ban on
further purchase of Russian oil and also
guests of course guess via repowerive
strategy but soon will not have any
guess imports from Russia and we
supported and encouraged member State
states to take all necessary measures to
keep Energy prices manageable such as
capping windfall profits infra marginal
pricing on electricity Market social
welfare actions to directly support
vulnerable citizens and smes and now we
are looking to the electricity Market
design register proposal next Tuesday to
be adopted by the College of
Commissioners this will be also
extremely relevant and significant to
help us to reduce the consequences of
the war on the energy Market in the
European Union but also will provide the
necessary tools to our electricity
Market to be better prepared for
eventually future crisis thank you so
much
thank you very much the flow to Madame
commissioner
Parliament and we just had a very good
Exchange in data committee on the first
anniversary of the Republic
you plan
and looking back to the past year the
Russian war against Ukraine as well as
the weaponization of energy and kicked
off an unprecedented transition
you plan our response to nit Market
disruptions has enabled a huge
shift in the EU Energy System and I
shared with eight to committee our
assessment of how far we have come in
delivering green power EU and the
numbers speak for themselves
um let me give you the basic facts
Europe has dramatically cut Imports of
Russian Pipeline gas down to around 20
billion cubic meters this year and
Russia is no longer the number one gas
supplier to Europe it is Norway golden
oil imports are now banned by our strong
sanctions even countries highly
dependent of Russian gas like German or
landlocked czechia have announced that
they are close to or have completed
phase out the Russian gas and one of the
most notable changes concerns the U gas
infrastructure in less than one year we
have greatly expanded the portfolio of
23 LNG regas education terminals we have
eight new ssru or LNG terminal opened or
under development and this will boost EU
reclassification capacity to some
227 billion cubic meters by 2024 from
the current
178 PCM our total energy Imports were 80
billion cubic meters in 2021 and
135 BCM in 2022 coming up
68 percent
it's as important as diversification for
our increased efficiency reduced demand
and then acceleration of Renewables and
I want to give you just two examples gas
demand in Europe between August 22 and
January this year has gone down for an
amount
equivalent to 42 billion cubic meters of
gas and the deployment of Renewables
reached an all-time high and this has
ensured that the European green deal
transition has not been compromised on
the contrary last year carbon emissions
dropped in Europe by two and a half
percent
and this is a positive Tech record but
it is not to the end of the story that
is why today I brought um committee two
messages
first you cannot let the where God down
on gas security supply
um common storage policy and coordinated
cost demand reduction will be needed
also for this year and we may also still
have a difficult summer ahead of us not
only winter with high temperatures and
throat influencing electricity
production and consumption so we are
still in uncharted waters and we must
reinforce preparedness and I'm going to
propose to member states to prolong the
voluntary demand reduction by 15 percent
until next year and this has worked well
and it is best granted achieve also
adequate level of storage by November
and my second message was on Renewables
yes we have exceeded our own goals but
this is not enough high prices
disruption in Supply chains red tape
they are putting pressure on our
Renewables industry I'm putting at risk
our targets for deployment and we must
do better on the renewable side to
progress through Power you so Renewables
they are homegrown cheapest and cleanest
form of energy production 2023 must be
another record year of Renewables as
well as the year after
let me conclude with the following Point
all the reforms of last year have been
possible thanks to the unity of member
states and the commission which have
acted in a remarkable
purely the first purpose from sanctions
to
Energy emergency legislation but this is
also the result of millions of Europeans
who have adjusted their Lifestyles and
cut down their energy consumption
everyone has played their part and I
have also recalled to the committee our
support to Ukraine's energy sector as a
key part of free Power EU
this will continue for as long as it is
needed for as long as Ukraine will
prepare
thank you very much Dr berol De Flores
yours
so many things so it was a great
pleasure to talk with the the members of
the parliament I made three points their
colleagues first which is the first year
one year after the invasion of Ukraine
by the largest energy exporter of the
world which is Russia so what are the
implications of that globally and also
for Europe and I said that unlike many
people have taught
including those in Kremlin Europe uh
European student freeze and European
economy didn't collapse
and what we have seen on the contrary
that the Russian oil and gas revenues
declined by 40 percent in one year of
time
we have seen the European Renewables
heat pumps electric cars they did it all
increase
we have seen that we have not had a
accident of a major blackouts and again
unlike many people have thought
European emissions last year did see a
significant decline of 2.5 percent
whereas the global emissions increased
so putting goal of distance together
Europe
a country that was having a over
Reliance on Russia in terms of its
energy
achieving these results bringing the
Russian oil and gas revenues down
increasing the renewable heat pumps and
electric cars no blackouts and bring the
emissions 2.5 degrees down I think it's
a success and therefore I congratulated
all EU and EU institutions here the
second point however I met is that the
next winter winter 23 24 might be
even much more challenging than the
winter we have now for a few reasons on
the markets but also maybe some of the
governments are being overly confident
because of the achievements we have this
year
and I made some suggestions there to the
final point I made I suggested that the
European industry
is facing huge pressures
short medium and longer term for two
reasons one the European economic model
which is based on abundant and cheap
Russian energy supplies is per se it is
over it will not go back there so
European energy will be on the higher
side compared to its competitors in
terms of gas electricity Surprises with
China with United States and others how
we are going to build a new European
industry how they are going to design it
is a one pressure point and the second
pressure point is
a divert is entering a new Industrial
Age
the age of clean energy technology
Manufacturing
but there is solar panels event means
electrolyzers and Europe is today in
many of them well behind than it is
competitors in terms of the
manufacturing capacity and in terms of
the uh the legal context they have put
together in incentives and the my appeal
to my colleagues where it is now time to
come up with a new
European industry master plan by looking
at these two pressures on one hand the
higher energy costs compared to your
competitors and the second one is the
how we are going to compete in the age
of clean Edge technology manufacturing
with the major players in the world so
these were three points I mentioned to
Madame commissioner Mr chairman members
of parliament and others thank you thank
you very much it's no question time
priority to the room uh first sir please
my name is erdo perbout work for VRT
Belgian television I have a question on
the the Imports of Russian LNG which in
fact has increased notably through the
port of uh in Belgium there was a double
doubling of the Imports of Russian LNG
Russia is also using European facilities
to to Transit LNG to to China and thus
Russia is still earning a lot of money
through this export do you think Europe
should consider a ban on importing and
transiting of Russian LNG
the question to to all of you
right now we don't have sanctions in
place covering Russian gas or LNG but uh
but indeed we do see that in five member
states the share of Russian melanchi has
increased and this brings uh clearly
reputational risk to the buyers from
European side because uh
um if some landlocked
countries who have been very dependent
on Pipeline supplies from Russia really
are in difficult to do
to replace pipeline gas fast with
Alternatives then this is not the case
in LNG market and this is why I have
asked ministers at energy Council
earlier this year to address this topic
with their industry and indeed
um I do believe that there is no need to
renew the contracts these Russian
suppliers
thank you very much uh yes sir please
thank you for the floor my name is Mrs
Kruger National News Agency of Ukraine
commissioner if I am a Ukraine Moldova
and both Balkan states are taking part
in current purchase of gas what volumes
we are speaking about and will it be
enough to overcome the next winter and
to all the panel as we know uh tonight
in Ukraine we have a mass missile strike
and uh the zapore Asia nuclear plant
again came out of the electricity grid
so that I understand it's mainly
question for international atomic energy
but anyway what is your reaction that
events and what kind of reaction could
be reached in international fora on such
kind of black nuclear blackmailing thank
you
I have been in contact with Ukraine
Minister energy Minister and later today
we will have extraordinary video call
exactly addressing this
emergency situation in Europe biggest
nuclear power plant in saporosia we
strongly support all the initiatives
that would allow us to create security
Zone around this nuclear power plant
because occupying civil nuclear power
plant is against all the international
agreements and um
as it is right now as we said
since uh since the occupation started
um
creates very dangerous situations
and might end in ecological disaster
on on the gas joint purchase side
our joint purchase platform was open for
all EU member states and energy
community members indeed Moldova Ukraine
and Serbia indicated their need for next
winter and
um and this is
now part of our
um
volumes negotiated you can
expect that that in April
um there will be there will be next
steps on
on our behalf but uh but I think that it
is not a secret that Ukraine has
indicated that uh on top of their own
domestic production they might need for
secure winter another 2 billion cubic
meters
um and
we will be able to
purchase this on on behalf of EU member
states and energy Community countries
thank you very much yes please
thank you Lex
um commissioner
um you said that European member states
should not renew the contracts for
Russian LNG but there will be a former
proposal from the commission to to
obtain this it's yes or no question and
the other question it it seems at least
to the press that the inclusion of
nuclear energy in the net zero industry
acts is a little bit controversial so
what do you think like nuclear energy
should be inside the Net Zero industry
act and so uh be
facilitated in permitting and
[Music]
even if the answer is yes or no what do
you think is the role of nuclear energy
in the future energy mix of Europe thank
you
I think that um at this stage five days
before we'll present NetZero in the
Stacked it's not important but I think
but it is important what will be a legal
decision of the commission and uh and I
know that next Tuesday there will be a
dedicated press conference explaining
what was uh agreed
um I myself from the piles that are
under my responsibility uh will um
respect the technological neutrality and
you can expect that this approach is
clearly visible also in a tested Market
design proposal
now about the contracts that European
companies and not member states these
are companies
um private sector who still do have
contacts with Russian gas problem
um what will they do after these
contracts will expire
um
I think that it is important that they
will not uh
renew them because this also gave us a
clear signal to our trusted partners
that that by not prolonging contracts we
are limiting
Russian ability to manipulate again with
our markets thank you
thank you yes please
newspaper Mexico Europe is looking for
partners and one of these Partners could
be Mexico and Mr 30 year old you were
very excited of the reform of Mexico
many years ago some years has been
passed I would like to know your
analysis about this reform and
commissioner you look forward for for
the cooperation with Mexico in this
field thank you
so the I think Mexico is a huge country
one of the cornerstones of the global
energy markets is a major hydrocarbon
producer but also huge renewable energy
resources but whether or not these
resources this potential will meet the
market is a question of investment and
having the right policies in place
Mexican governments made a good step in
the right direction but if you ask me
whether or not they have achieved what
the full potential is my answer is not
yet I have to say that if I can
the chairman I want to make a point on
the nuclear as well that our colleagues
just ask I cannot stop myself because
nuclear is a global issue I can assure
you that the nuclear around the world is
making a comeback
in Japan in Korea in United States in
Canada China India and Middle East it is
completely up to the countries to choose
which option they are going to use but
in that respect in my view uh to turning
our back in Europe to nuclear power
without finding from a cost
and Emissions perspective and equivalent
alternative may not be the best way to
go in terms of the competitors of the
European economy I think we need to
think twice before making decisions in
that direction
thank you the last question yes please
can you hear me yes
um
I have a question about the Net Zero act
again sorry do you think that would be
enough or kind of enough to make the EU
economically independent for its energy
system and how do you plan to to fund it
thank you for this question and I
strongly believe that we have to support
clean tech industry where Europe still
has a competitive Advantage compared to
the other markets but this cannot be
limited to only these sectors because
in the past of us climate totality we
will need um different Technologies and
we cannot create new dependencies so we
have to cover also these sectors where
otherwise if we don't bring some the
production back to Europe or if we don't
diversify our supply routes we will rate
new vulnerabilities
and uh and um financing is actually
available already but uh but this Net
Zero in the sect is not addressing only
financing but also other bottlenecks
starting from permitting for Green Field
installations for example and also this
is a year of skills so what we hear from
clean tech industry Representatives we
have to also address
the shortage of skilled Workforce and
all these aspects will be covered this
uh this act I hope that that
these uh
um the sectors that we will cover are
clearly
um clearly the sectors where we have no
regret
um the support them thank you if I may
add just one sentence uh clearly it will
not be enough but it's a major step
forward building on what we did already
fit for 55 repower you we need also not
only regulatory measures but also we
need incentives and the the industry and
also the investors in Clean Energy
Solutions are waiting for for this
initiative as Republic as not only our
strategy to phase out Russian Imports to
not have any more Russian Imports for
fossil fuels and especially guests
because the others there is already a
ban but also help us will help us
repower you to reach our climate goals
and will give to our consumers to our
population and to our industry better
prices more reliable prices more decent
prices and more stable prices in the
future and now European commission we
expect in the parliament will come with
this a kind of strategy that also brings
more financing because the financing is
already there and new incentives that
the industry and the population I sure
will welcome
thank you so much thank you very much we
have more than exhausted the time that
was located to us if you have further
questions please get in touch uh we will
find a way to to give you an answer
thanks for the interpreters and have a
very good afternoon
thank you